。
先说一下这个这部电影华尔街之狼，嗯嗯这部电影时长是3个小时，然后呢在国内有个这个这个进化版啊呃两个半小时删掉了半小时之多，删掉了半小时之多，说明这部电影确实。
呃，尺度非常大啊，水肌精华也可以来学习一下这部电影啊。嗯，有几个原因吧。嗯，第一，这部电影呢确实是一个传世佳作啊，华尔街之狼是很多商界人啊嗯一没有精神了，就看一遍这个电影嗯，包括我本人。
同学们嗯，在我的人生当中，有几部电影是我呃低潮的时候或者心情不好的时候，我就会去看一遍的电影，给我力量的电影啊，嗯这是其中一部华尔街之狼就是其中一部。当然了，还有绿野仙踪啊，39年的绿野仙踪。然后来。
还有丹泽尔华盛顿啊丹泽尔华盛顿深渊人啊，嗯有的有的就是爆米花电影。嗯，有的是这种啊，当然了还有喜剧之王啊，喜剧之王。嗯，我这这几部电影在我人生当中都是看过几十遍的啊嗯。
在人生低潮的时候，可可以给人以力量。华尔街之狼呢就是在你商业上进行的不顺的时候，它给你一种狼性文化啊，狼性文化就是90年代从美国的销售，七80八九十年代从美国的销售兴起的啊，所以说这个这个电影叫华尔街之狼嘛。呃另外确实。
嗯，马丁导演啊，马丁斯克塞斯在这个电影里啊展现了极致的疯狂，展现了极致的想象力。然后迪卡普利奥在这部电影里面，他配得上啊一个小金人，但是没有给他嗯，败给谁了来着，我有点忘了，反正这个华尔街之狼是迪卡普利奥。
没有得到小金人最委屈的一次啊呃他那年是真应该得。
呃，小金儿即便是他后来通过荒野猎人弥补了这个遗憾。但说实话，荒野猎人真的就是呃我觉得是业界去安慰安慰这个迪up，给了他一个小金人呃，相当于向他道歉。华尔街之狼没有给他嗯，华尔街之狼是确实是应该。
嗯，拿到。
嗯。
最佳男主角了啊。另外这个故事里面的那个感情线啊，即使小丑女，也演过芭比啊女演员。
呃，也是值得值得欣赏的啊啊。对，那一届给了马修了啊，那一届当然了，迪卡普利奥，你说输给马修麦康纳冤不冤呢？其实不冤。
这就是神仙打架嘛。
但问题是确实是呃华尔街之郎是迪卡普利奥呃演技生涯的巅峰，输给马修布员啊，他的华尔街之狼是他演技的一个巅峰。迪卡普利奥饱受。
呃，他的长相困扰啊呃这个演员从一出道，从十几岁出道之后就一直饱受他的长相的一个困扰。因为他长得实在是太帅了啊，曾经有多年。
被评为世界上最帅的人，这个事情吧严重影响了他的大家对他演技的认可。然这个事情确实也是一种长得太帅，可能也是一种诅咒吧。
这个咱们大部分人没有这并没有这个体体验，很难共情啊，很难共情他太帅了。这故事节拍也比较长，非常长。
来，我说一下啊，第一排。
一分钟。
这个故事显显然有点插叙啊，先把后面的一场戏拎上来。
拎的哪一场呢？拎的是实几拍的时候是吧？实际拍的时候，这个待会再说啊，那后面是一场拎啊。
展现疯狂之后的一个呃展现成功后的他的疯狂状态。首先上上来就展现了这个人对别人机器不重用，是吧？呃欺负弱势群体那小小小侏儒。
配上独白自我介绍。嗯，看过的同学都知道这部电影啊各种独白，因为是传记体嘛，必须是主角自己的声音啊特有代入感。然后他的非常的成功，也交代了一下他的出身，他现在生活是什么？豪车、豪宅、美女游艇、飞机对吧？富豪生活，而且传播了一定的。
这个生活理念啊啊这部电影演讲很多，待会我们看一一些名卡面可以看简单看一下啊。
来到第二排第五分钟，简单回顾一下它是怎么成长起来了啊。简单回顾一下他怎么成长。很多同学认为说这部电影讲的是呃一个人的成功和失败，对吧？如果让我们写传题体啊，我们可能会写这个人的成功和失败，然后在中间做一个转点，就是他可定要下。
怎么往下走，这是我们一般人会这么写啊。但是这部电影其实是从巅峰开始写的。呃，他他的出他的那个下位史只是简单交代，基本上是讲一个人的堕落啊，他是从顶往往下写的，讲的是一个人逐步堕落，逐步被FBI击败啊。
来嗯第二拍序5分钟啊，回忆他的创业初期来了华尔街啊。嗯第一份工作呢在这个罗斯柴尔德做电话销售啊，展现了他的环境和技能。他是个天生的啊天生的sellereller啊。嗯，这个由于是真人改编。所以说这个人呢他是一个天生的销售，嗯，跟老师一样啊，属marketing。
玩的玩销售sales啊，来到第三拍第7分钟啊导师一个名场面。嗯，马修麦康纳在这部电影里面轻微的客串了一下，呃，教我们的主角如何成为一个真正的销售啊。因为他本身就很有天赋，但是还是需要导师点播。而且呢这个马修麦康纳唱出的的那个狼之歌。
那个那个歌啊，在后面有个呼影，我们看一下吧。呃，这场戏堪称神仙打架啊。嗯这个如此彪悍的迪卡普利奥啊，在马修麦康纳的控制下，基本上节奏就被带跑跑偏了啊，因为很多演员都反映说跟马修麦康娜一起对戏。
会完全被他带走啊，看一下大神怎么演戏啊，这部电影太长了，我们能看的片段不多，我们就珍惜一下啊。
嗯嗯，对不起。
can straight precisely seven and one after that you're going to bring us two more then two more after that every five until one of us passes the sir'm good you.
Its his first day on Wall Street, give him time thank you thank you.
re able to.
During the and then still' else would you do this job cocaine anders my friend?
I got to say I'm incredibly excited to be a party firm.
Clients you have are absolutely fuck the clients.
Your only responsibility is to put meat on the table.
You got a girlfriend'm married have Thereesaulationesa the game the money from your client's pocket into your pocket right, but if you can make a client's money at the same time it's advantageous to everyonem correct no.
Number one rule of Wall Street, nobody I don't if you're a Warren buffett or if you're Jimmy Buffet, nobody knows if the stock is going to go up down sideways are in fucking circles at least of all stock brokers it's all the fuhazi you know fuzi isgezi, it's a fake fuzi fuuzzzi, it's a w it's a woozy it's a fairy dust, it doesn't exist, it's never landed, it is no matter, it's not on the elemental chart, it's not fucking real, right right.
再问没嗯哼。
We don't create shit, we don't build anything so if you got a client who bought stock at eight and announce it's at 16 and he's all fucking happy, he wants to cash in liquidate take his bucket money and run home you don't let him do that okay because that would make it real right what do you do you get another brilliant idea a special idea?
Another situation, another stock to reinvest his earnings and then and he will every single time because they're fucking addicted and then he just keep doing this again and again, and again, meanwhile, he thinks he's getting shit rich, which he is on paper but you and me the brokers we're taking home cold hard cash via commission month.
right.
It's incredible, sir can't tell you how excited I am you should be, there two keys to success in the broker business first of all.
You got to stay relaxed.
你觉得。
多多支狗哎。
Yeah how many times a week.
Like three three four three four times maybe I bump those numbers up, those are rookie numbers in this racket, by myself, I jerk off at least twice a day.
in the morning right after a workout and then once right after lunch, really, okay, I want to, that's not why I do it, I do it because I fucking need to.
You're dealing with dayal high frequencies acidardeseing.
This tip this prescription if you dont happen run bathroom anyll be about money.
Second key to success in this racket is this little baby right here, it's called cocaine.
It will keep you sharp between the ears, it'll also help your fingers dial faster and guess what, that's good for me.
Yes。
Revols you follows keep the clients on the fairs will and it goes the park is open 247365 every decade, every goddamed century that's it name of the game.
嗯，than you.
嗯嗯嗯。
嗯嗯哼。
嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯。
误。
包括评奖啊也是这样，总觉得挨打呀、受虐呀，这是一种演技。其实不是啊挨打受虐或者为角色牺牲，那是一种意志力。演技其实是你看这种戏，这才叫演演技啊，呃这才是真正的这个影帝啊，能够让你一秒入戏，让你这个这个相信他他就是这个角色，包括迪卡布利奥在对面演演出来的那种第一天上班的一个菜鸟啊，他们叫ruokie呃这个这个这个的一种尴尬，对吧？那老板说一些很不着调的话，你的上司说一些很不着调的话，在公共场合呢，行为很不不雅，然后呢。
呃，这个这个你的这种尴尬呃，但是你又不得不迎合。你像这种情况啊，我们说是典型的非常考演技的。好，来到第四盘15分钟啊，黑色星期一股市大跌，行业完蛋了啊，公司倒闭，需要重新找工作。第五拍来到第18分钟。
新工作啊去找了一个新工作，那个环境很差啊，但是可以卖那个仙股啊，他们叫这个实际上就是没有上市，私自上市啊。然后加呃因为它的天赋一禀啊，迅速的卖出了第一单，开始了这个新新的这个征程啊。第六盘22分钟。
他的伙伴那个胖子啊搭讪登场，成为他的跟班啊，这个人呢也是特别能胡扯的一个人设啊，也是非常适合做销售。因为他本身也是个销售嘛，这部电影后面他招募的所有人都是销售啊，因为在那个年代确实销售成为了第一批致富的人来到第棋盘27分钟啊，开始创业，从办公室招募团。
对，然后培训大家的技能，包括那个著名的麦比，第八拍31分钟，创业成功啊，继续他的富裕生活。
呃，同学们啊，在这里我要说一下，这部电影基本上是从巅峰开始写的。所以说他前面没有讲他是如何苦，如何打拼，因为他上来就是天赋一禀啊，第九拍32分钟，重新打造公司啊，经过他老婆的启发，他决定把这些垃圾股卖给有钱人，不能只卖给穷人啊，有钱人也是可以被说服的。
each产生了公司的新策略啊，然后第十part36分钟，那这个公司就飞速发展了啊，飞速发展赚大钱。1一拍37分钟啊，庆祝公司的业绩啊逐渐走向疯狂。庆祝仪式上有个比较典型的一个案例，就是给他的助理PP了一个光头啊。
他呢对女孩子非常不友好节1二拍来到第40分钟，被执法部门盯上了啊，对手登场，而且媒体开始称他为华尔街之狼。我们说第一幕结束的时候啊，啊对手登场，威胁开始啊呃你可以理解同学们这个故事讲的就是一个销售天才。
如何走下神坛的这么一个故事线。那所以他的第一幕最终把他拉下神坛的那个对手，在第一幕就登场了，然后开始了目标啊。由于这个电影是被动权的目标，传记体，所以说从这个角度去分啊呃再加上这部电影是三个小时啊，所以他的四幕其实分分的非常规整。
450540啊，基本上是这么一个结论。我们说他被对手盯上，最终这个对手干掉他，第一幕就结束了啊，这个对手盯上他。
他也正式被称之为华尔街之狼啊， such踏上了他的狼的征途。来到第十三拍第二幕啊，十三拍C一成钟嗯，他这个华尔街之狼这个名号走红了以后呢，事业更上一层楼。呃，进入第二幕之后呢，来了一段游戏时光能太奇啊，伙伴们也纷纷成型了。
父亲也加盟了啊，游戏时光啊，我们说争到第二幕基本上就是一通蒙开奇在41分钟我们开。
是ma。
With E parts, cocaine, testosterone and body fluids Strattons very own Gestala.
第1分钟质逐渐。
啊，在这里呢父亲有一个不好的预言啊，我们说呃像加入父亲这种角色或者加入导师这种角色啊，他肯定要放点放点那个那个那个flag出来的啊。然后是515拍啊，50分钟泳池派对泳池派对呢新的姑娘加入啊，泳池派对是接着前面他这个淫荡的生活继续往前推的。
呃，但是呢也不能没有信息量。所以这个这场戏呢既发现了一个新商机，就是后面那个女鞋IPO的事儿，然后又发现了一个新的姑娘，在这部片子里面叫什么？
叫naomi是吧？呃，16part55分钟开始约会占入爱河，又是一段蒙太奇呃，结束上一段婚姻，开启新的生活。
然后第17拍63分钟，有一个管家偷钱事件，在这里打一个呃标记啊，这个管家偷钱事件要不要这场戏没有什么很大的用啊，干单纯的去惹了一下同性这件事啊，十八拍65分钟。我们说这个电影亵渎的人还是非样多的啊，亵渎各种东西。18拍65分钟啊，然后开始处理黑钱，黑户呀律师呀，对吧？事业线，继续我回到事业线啊，回到我们的事业线。
19拍67分钟求婚这个新的女友啊，婚前派对啊、婚礼啊、游艇呀、新生活开启啊。20拍啊，71分钟18个月之后啊，这段新的婚姻生活又开始吵架了。呃，回到了开头的时间线啊。嗯我们说这场戏回到开头的时间线。然后21拍77分钟，帮客户IPO。
啊，有一个激情的演讲演场面，22拍87分钟啊，对手毕届。我们说这场IPO名演讲讲了10分钟，非常厉害啊，抵卡李老钟台词功力看一看要吧。
Take a moment to tell you why Steve here is so absolutely off the fucking wall.
Because this man.
Is a creative genius.
This ability, this gift that Steve has, that goes beyond just spotting the hotest shoe trends, Steve's power.
Is that he creates trends, you understand?
Arists like Steve come along once every decade, I'm talking Geio Almani Gianni Pisacechi, Coco Chanel, Ial Laent Steve, come up here for a second, I don't think you all realize.
That Steve Madden is the hottest person in the women's shoe industry with orders going through the roof at every department store in North America right now, we have him here at our office.
We should think our fucking lucky stars. This man is here. This is our golden ticket in a fucking chocolate factory right here. And I want to meet Li fucking Waka. Okay, I want to do with the fucking overs like this get off the fucking stage. get here.
All right, we want all you to focus for a second, see those little black boxes, they're called telephones, I'm going to let you on a little secret about these telephones and not going to dial themselves, okay, without you, they're just worthless hunks of plastic, like a loaded M16 without a train re to pull the trigger.
And in the case of the telephone.
It's up to each and every one of you.
My highly trained strattonites.
My killers.
My killers who will not take no for an answer.
fuckinguck warriors who will not hang up the phone until their client either buys or fucking die.
Let me there is no nobility in poverty, I have been a rich man and I have been a poor man, and I choose rich every fucking time.
when I have to face my problems, I show up in the back of a limo wearing a $2,000 suit and a $40,000 gold fucking watch.
Thinks I'm superficial or materialistic. go get a job at fucking McDonald's, because that's why you fucking belong.
But before you depart this room for the winners.
I want you to take a good look at the person next year go on.
Cause sometime in the not so distant future, you're going to be pulling up to a red light and you beat up old fucking pinnel and that person is going to be pulling up right alongside you in that brand new poors.
Some disgusting wild debe with three days a raiseous stubble in a sleeveless mo crammed in next you a call load full of groceries from a fucking price club. That's who you're gonna be sitting next. So you listen to me and you listen well, Are you behind on your credit card bills, Go pick up the phone and start dialing. is your landlord ready to evict you.
Good, pick up the phone and start dialing Does your girlfriend think you're a fucking worthless loser, Good pick up the phone and start dialing I want you to deal with your problems by becoming rich All you have to do today is pick up that phone.
peak the words that I have taught you, and I will make you richer than the most powerful CEO in the United States of F America I want you to go out there.
I want you to ram Steve Maddenstock down your client' throats till they fucking choke on it till they choke on it and they buy10000 shares, That's what I want You be ferocious, You'd be relentless, You be telephone fucking.
常牛一戏啊。
啊，跟大家说一下，你看像刚才这个啊呃同学们，我为什么说这场这个电影其实它有些地方还是有正面意义的啊，他最起码说对了一件事情，就是关于赚钱，我如何快速的获得别人的注意力啊。他刚才说golden tickets啊，这个非常对，你用三段式怎么回答说服别人第一段第一段。
你赚不到钱，是因为你没有买票，先讲一个让他思考奇怪的事实。什么票呢？坐在有钱人那桌的门票，你没有没有这个门票，有没有坐在有钱人那桌。因为有钱人里面有90%的人并不知道咱自己是怎么赚到钱的。
他只是坐对了桌，因为发明方法论的只有10%的人。第三点，你也不需要知道方法论，你不需要道世界运行的规律，你只需要坐在有钱人那一桌。
说这种就三段式啊三段式正好结合他在讲赚钱，大家去体会一下如何用三段式写台词啊，包括去说服别人。
22拍87分钟，对手逼近啊，FBI继续调查，主角开始担心开口对策，然后23盘。
我们的主角去约谈对手啊，试图贿赂对方，结果谈崩了谈崩了，而且把自己暴露了啊，正式宣价。我们说故事来到了终点，正式宣价。
然后24拍98分钟转换目标了啊，股是进入第三步转换目标，开始要把资产转移到海外了。因为对方确实是意识到对方要干自己。然后25拍是100分钟在飞机上闯货啊，在这里飞机上闯货这场戏为什么单拎出来呢？是因为在暗示他的几个困境啊，他有几个困境啊？
药物困境和家庭困境以及他的伙伴啊，这些都是暴雷的，他的药物困扰已经很严重了啊，26拍102分钟啊，嗯去到那个瑞士的银行去谈如何藏钱。在这个店里大家也看到这个所谓的中帝国的这种银行啊，其实嘴里也不咋地，27拍105分钟进到下一个目标。他在欧洲藏钱的话，需要找一个欧洲亲戚，也就是那个姨妈啊。
28拍109分钟，人肉往欧洲运钱啊，闯在人身上。但是呢开始暗示团队内部开始有矛盾隐患了，就是他两个伙伴最不靠谱的两个伙伴有矛盾啊。
然后第29拍112分钟，这个矛盾直接就引发危机了。然后其中一个被警他抓了。30拍来到115分钟啊，为了掩盖失误，他的伙伴呢给他下药，两个人一起嗨。我们说那个胖子啊确实挺碍事的。31拍118分钟危机爆发啊，药效也爆发。然后呢他试图回家，这是也是一个明场面的戏啊，这场戏拍的也是非常有意思，他认为自己是怎么回家，以及第二天复盘是怎么回家，特别有意思啊。
然后32拍124分钟。
女呢和他的伙伴在家里战斗啊，包括急救呀，也出现一个濒死状态啊，人工呼吸。33拍127分钟醒来之后啊，被警察呃抓起来呃，因为危险驾驶，34盘来到129分钟，危机暂时度过去了，但是对手盯他盯得更紧了啊，他产生了一个新的解决方案。
本来是往欧洲运钱，现在又有一个新的解决方案，也就是认罪认罪的话就代表他要那个辞职啊，认罪交罚款，他辞职就不能干这个，结果来到35拍132分钟啊，他开始了自己辞职演说。但是还是这个人特别是口口才太好了啊。
说着说着自己又又也入戏了，结果司会协议决定继续战斗。
而且也呼应了他开场的那个狼之歌啊，我们来看一下这场戏吧，这场戏写来还是非常不错的。
I want to thank you all for your years of loyalty and admiration, but the point is this.
Donnie's leadership along with Nikki Kosoff and Robbie Feinberg moving into key management positions, this place really it's going to be better than ever that I promise see.
This is Ellis Island you people Okay who you are, where you're from, whether your relatives came over on the fucking Mayflower or an int from Haiti, this right here the land of opportunity Stratton Oakmont is America.
All of you know Kimmy Bels are right Yes we do you Come on Jimmymy, which you probably didn't know is Kimmy was one of the first brokers here, one of Stratton's original 20.
Most of you met Kimmy, the beautiful, sophisticated woman that she is today, a woman that wears $3000 armmani suits, drives a brand new Mercedes Benz.
A woman who spends her winters in the Bahamas and the summers in the Hamptons.
Something kid that I met.
Kim me that I met didn't have two nickels to rub together.
She was a single mom on the balls of a with an eight year old son.
She was three months behind on her rent.
And when she came to me and asked me for a job.
She asked for a $5,000 advance just so she could pay a son's tuition.
What do.
You wrote me a check.
$25000.
And you know where that is?
belved的你。
Because I believed in you coming.
Just like I believe in each and every one of you here today, I fucking love you, Jordan, fucking I fucking love you, I love you, I fucking love you too.
I love all youI love all you my my.
For years, I've been telling you guys never to take no for an answer, right?
Pushing to never hang up the phone.
You get what you want.
You allt deserve it.
You know this fucking deal that I'm about to sign.
Baring me from the securities industry, baring me from stratton.
同。
在没 know。
what it is.
It's me taking no for an answer, you know?
It's them selling me not the other way around.
Maybe in a hypocrite is what it is.
So。
没弄。
回不。
问一问。
那不 leaving.
fuck。
哦。
是大危机马上就要到了啊，因为这是第三步了嘛，大危机马上就要到了。然后36拍来到1138分钟，那个伙伴出狱之后，他们给大家开party啊，见证上party展现了他们继续疯狂，继续藐视法规。然后37拍来到139分钟FBI的调查BB步步逼近啊，开始审问每一个人。
38拍141分钟被出卖啊，抛售股票呃，欧洲的阿姨也挂了啊，已经放在银行的脏钱也保不住了，整个进入一个大危机啊，49拍为了挽住这个危机啊，去摩洛哥遇到海上风暴啊，打决战翻翻船了，可以说这基本上就是。
然后40拍148分钟被打捞上来啊，被一个过路过的船打捞上来，包括那个来救他们的飞机还失事了。他认为自己得到上帝的指引，也就是获得的新的方法啊，重新解决一个新的方法。41拍139分钟主角要在拍广告拍宣传片的时候被抓了啊，42拍150分钟全员被捕啊，全员被捕被起诉，然后保释。
43分钟153分钟落难之后呢，伙伴对他进行支持，开始他也开始了比较自律的生活，实际上是有一点点要好转的情况了。
然后44排155分钟，检方又给主角提供了一个方案，就是希望他那个呃配合调查，也就是带上那个窃听器去查其他人啊，否则将会面临非常漫长的刑期。
45拍157分钟啊，他的家庭出现危机，妻子要离开他，然后要离婚，结果他又开始了啊，他又开始用服用这个毒品了。嗯甚你想卡孩子逃跑啊，失败。也就是说在这里啊，他被爱情出卖，那你可以理解，爱情出卖164分钟，46拍，164分钟。
他正式成为了简化的卧底啊，回到公司，但是他还是不忍心出卖他的伙伴啊嗯，后面被他的伙伴给出卖了。
也就是说，上一拍是爱情出卖了他，下一拍是友情出卖了他，他不愿意出卖友情，但是友情出卖了他。
47拍啊，167分钟，检方发现主角这个他被那个伙伴出卖了啊，警方发现了，把他送进了监狱。
但是呢他也出卖了其他人啊，这个都被抓走了。然后48拍170分钟啊，最终服刑三年。嗯，监狱里面的这个呃生活简单展示了一下呃，49拍172分钟啊，呃用一个真人脱口秀啊结束全片又回到了那个麦比的名场面。
我们说这个电影啊分钟数1。
非常之长，我拉了49拍啊，接近50拍的一个情况，三个小时的片子。我们说总体故事讲的是什么？总体的故事就是讲一个人的坠落啊，由于他这个坠落并不是主动的。
对吧他是被人调查嘛，所以你可以理解他的主故事线确实没有那么的明确啊，他的讲上的坠落。很多同学说是大起大落，其实不是啊，从高点一直在往下走。
基本上是从高点一直的往下走啊，我们说这是一个呃传记体的一个故事，叫一个人半生的时光。
这种这种故事。
我们来说一下这个故事有什么特点，这样的故事有什么特点？
第一个特点，首先是不是有大量的独白啊？
第二呢，阶段性的目标或者困境啊不能断，否则就散掉了。因为它时间跨度很长，又没有主目标线。
所以他阶段性的目标和困境一直没有断过，也是也是以此为推进剧情的。
然后呢，第三点就是稍微用了一下非线性叙事，把后面的一场戏往前提了，因为没有悬念嘛。
最后一点最重要的一点啊。
其实很多同学可能看这个电影的时候没体会。
最重要的一点，我说这个电影好看啊，这个传记电影好看，最重要的一点是什么？
是太花钱。
拍了太多场戏了。
有的场景就用了几秒，但是耗费了大量的人力物理去拍。
同学们，这个电影换场啊。
这个电影换场实实在是太多了，花了太多钱了，这是一部非常烧钱的电影。
我们说烧钱的电影不是说做段那个特效，同学们打仗放炮飞机。
是换场呀，换这么多场，消耗这么多人啊。
嗯，这个。
同学们可以理解这个戏很爽。
其实跟这个非常有关系啊，消耗演员可能都是当时都是创纪录的啊，消耗的场景和演员都是创纪录的，非常的花钱。
这是钱堆出来的一个爽感。这个电影非常的奢侈，拍的非常奢侈。
好吧。
另外呢我们再来研究一下。
他用了一个小小的手法，同学们自己可以记一下。
他拍一个传记电影的时候。
它集合了很多时代元素。
同学们。
拍传记电影，由于是回顾过去的情况。
所以他结合了很多时代元素。
他利用主角的视角告诉他，哎，你看当时大家都在用这种。比如说啊我们要拍一个专辑电影，从90年代我会告诉大家，哎，当时呢大家都会对吧？看什么样的衣服。当时呢大家都会吃一种什么样的餐厅。当时呢大家会有什么样的零食？
这种时代烙印啊。
对于转据天也是非常重要的。
他是故意加上去的。同学们，你们仔细回顾一下，在这部片子里面。
讲了很多当时的时代烙印。
帮助大家啊帮助大家去共情。
这个也是我们如果要写我们说过，我们拉片是为了学习一类影片的写法。
这个传记题咋写嘛？
一个人那么一漫长的一生。
从哪选取哪一段呢？
主故事线怎么去理呢？
对不对？传记体的故事现在让你写，比如说你写。
咱随便布置个作业啊，比如说你就回忆你们家亲戚，对吧？你们家的亲戚里面，你觉得谁最值得拍一个传记故事，当然了，未必够得上能在院线上上上映的那种级别。但是最起码你们家从你们家的角度，你你觉得这个人比较适合做一个传记电影，那你就想你选举他的哪一段？
这个电影很明显选取的是一个人坠落。
一个天才的坠落。
他是个销售天才呀，很很明显是这样子呀。
所以你看既然确定了我要拍一个销售天才的坠落，那我就拍他坠落的过程。启程转合思幕式。
他先搞搞砸了自己的生活，然后呢又引起了FBI的注意。然后FBI来来干他的时候呢，他又采取了错误的连续采采取了两三次错误的选择啊贿赂人家，然后还放纵自己身边的伙伴，然后呢又又又最后又是给他机会，他不要，对吧？
他坚持自己的原则，呃，不去呃接受这个对方的和解。
明白吗？
我们说你看这个故事，他选的就是这个人的坠落过程。就是说这么屌的一个人，一个天才的销售员是怎么把自己搞搞砸了的？
好吧。
这个我们说这个主线啊是拍传记电影最重要的一个呃最难解决的一个问题就是把这个主线。另外呢当然了，你自己要做传记电影的时候，也要记住呃，咱们说的啊呃时代的烙印呀，包括那个场景的人物的丰富度呀，这些都是。
呃，挽救传记体电影的一一些手法，否则一个传记电影如果没有如此大咖的演员来称的话，实际是很无聊的。
如果没有这么多大咖的演员的演技，再加上呃不断的转换场景，不断的给新的视觉刺激。这种电影肯定是不好看。
但是这部电影。
没觉得闷是吧？大部分同学并没有觉得闷3个小时觉得还挺快乐。
好吧，这就是我们在这个电影当中要学的东西嗯。
传记体吧呃确实不那么主流啊，关于华尔街之狼这部电影我推荐给大家。
几个理由。
第一个理由，我们接这个电影学习一下传记题怎么写啊，这个确实是呃可以写的好看的，未必非要。
很严肃，或者未必非要很悲情啊，可以是好看的呃，这是学的第一个点。第二个点就是呃呃这个这个推荐给大家。第二点呢，就是大家去学习一下这个呃这部电影当中一些销售以及与人沟通的精神，我觉得是对我们生活是有帮助的。我们未必要做一个坏人啊，但是做一个能够。
呃，拥有强大气场啊，强大商业感染力的一个人也是不错的。第三点啊，我们也学习一下，嗯，我们说如果一个故事的主角，他不是个好人，对吧？这个电影的主角显然不是个好人，我们如何能够让观众共情，我们可以做一下调查。
来同学们，你们有多少人是担心这个主角而被抓走的？就是除了当然了，与与他与与与他是抵卡布利奥也有关系，对吧？我们当然知道他是个坏人，他做了太多缺德事儿了，对吧？但是呢我们实际上还是站在他这一边的对吧？很多同学还是站在他这一边的。
嗯嗯嗯就像这种角色怎么去塑造，对吧？怎么去塑造，塑造他还有有有有良心的那一面，还是说有兄弟情的那一面，对吧？嗯，这个东西我也是我们可以值得去研究的啊，再加上就是我刚才说过的啊，时代的这些元素啊，自己往上加一加。
好吧。